what is one of your favorite memories of
us for those of you that don't know i
took soleil moonfry to her prom
and ended up throwing her in the ocean
you were very popular
yo we're here in san diego
do you remember you picked me up from
school one day and 90210 had gotten
so big a friend wanted to come and you
guys couldn't tell people where the set
was and so she had to be blindfolded
because i loved such a huge them
i sort of stole a motorcycle and ended
up
driving it from hollywood out to your
house pretty sure the cops pulled us
over and yeah i guess i really wanted to
see you yes in the 90s no
drugs it's really crazy looking back i
ran into
johnny depp four five years ago at like
the golden globes
and did you even met him at your
birthday party
oh my god i love you guys so much
everyone is
cheering for you and they want you to
succeed because they love seeing you and
they love the energy that you bring
you do realize you always get me into
tears hey everyone it's soleil moonfry
and
i have the honor of interviewing my dear
friends
brian austin green and balthazar getty
only on e.t nice
good work great that was that's right i
felt good about it
oh brian i love you much i love you this
is
truly this is cool true how crazy is
this
you're sitting at this bar on the set of
e.t
like grown-ups like like kind of except
that we're not right
because i still feel like i'm such a kid
when i'm with you we were
literal kids when we met so this is
with the cameras around and the
documentary and all this is
it's a bit surreal as a teenager i
carried a video camera with me
everywhere i went i kept all of my
diaries
i kept every one of my voicemail
messages
i documented everything and then i
locked it away for over 20 years
what did you think when i told you that
i was doing this and
when you saw the footage you and your
brother running around with the camera
and filming everything and recording
everything and documenting everything
i didn't have the foresight at that time
to know like oh this is something she
can hold on to
and later in life watch back i think so
much of it was because
on a subconscious level i was just i was
putting away
so many of the memories your ability
though to um
to do that and think that far ahead in
your life at such a young age
is is such a testament
to who you are to me and
it's no wonder to me that that people
love they loved watching you when you
were a kid everyone is
cheering for you and they want you to
succeed because they love seeing you and
they love the energy that you bring
you do realize you always get me into
tears
[Laughter]
because as i looked through
out the memories in my mind and
the diaries and i talked about this in
the dark
you always showed up you were always
there for me
and you you have always been there for
me and
and i i'm so grateful for that first of
all thank you i take compliments
horribly so
i'm gonna say thank you first and then
say that
it wasn't it wasn't a choice with you it
wasn't like it wasn't a conscious choice
that i had to make you were like
hey this is going on i was like cool so
where do you need me to be like there
was no
that just wasn't even i was like can you
pick me up from school
that's just never i was the coolest girl
school by the way when you would come
and get me from school i have to say
really there was nothing cool yeah you
had like the coolest
car you were like the coolest thing you
were yeah
and you were a little bit older not used
to driving a stick
do you remember when you picked me up
from school one day and
and 90210 had gotten so big and
a friend wanted to come and and you guys
couldn't tell people where the set was
and so she had to be blindfolded
yes because i loved this
was so such a huge hit and you were like
that's such a moment
i thought i was just taking you and like
i trust you and i know you
but your friend's gonna have to get in
the truck i'm gonna have to tie her up
by the way
she literally had to put a blindfold on
and that was the only way that she was
allowed to come
that's right i'm so sorry i mean whoever
that friend was that
what if you're watching this i'm so
sorry that i gagged you and tied you up
in the trunk of the car
just to go to a set we worked in van
nuys we were next to a porn
that's how big the show was literally
there were like 12
kids in the business so we all knew
everyone we all knew each other you
speak about in the dark how there was
this group that were growing up together
what was that like for you i think it
took a bit of the pressure of
what i was doing being a career choice
out of it because there
there there was no competition it didn't
feel like within it it was i
i didn't have somebody that i would see
in a
uh in a waiting room auditioning for
something i'd go oh man
you know damn it seth green's here like
i'm never gonna get this now it was like
it was either seth green is your type or
i'm your type i was never popular in
school
i never hung out with certain groups i
would
like mingle around with everybody and
the first
the first group that i had in
in my life that i remember were other
actors like that was we all spent so
much time together and that was
that was us it was this inseparable
group
if there was a teen magazine trip going
on somewhere
we were the ones going it was like oh
who's going to be
don't ask who's going to be there you
know who's going to be there like it was
that was a silly question it was like
oh so we're all going to go out of town
for the weekend great
totally we went to san diego san diego
was
probably the best it was amazing we flew
there which is insane
literally do you remember well yeah the
the jumping from balconies
yeah yeah but the video that you showed
me and the doc was from
uh san diego san diego not for we we
took a few san diego trips but i
remember
and robin thicke and all of that whole
group and
it was wild and yeah we we got into a
little trouble
well it's amazing too how much honestly
is such a short
period of time in the in the grand
scheme
of life how much we've all gone through
and i i saw
somebody sent me an old picture of me
with leo and toby at some bowling thing
and
it's so funny because we're kids well
and it's it's it's
wild right crazy it's really crazy
looking back on like what
what life was and the people that we
were hanging out with then that were
just friends of ours i ran into
johnny depp four or five years ago at
like the golden globes
and did you did you i met him at your
birthday party at
i don't know what hotel that was but it
was him and
bubbles the chimp was there too for in
overalls
i started developing rapidly going from
a b to c to double d
to almost filling into an e and this all
happened between
the time that i finished punky till i
was 15.
for me it was really interesting going
from being a kid to then going through
puberty
and almost being thrusted into
adulthood in a way because i was
developing
so quickly yeah and so um i was treated
much differently even though i was still
so young i really wish that i was
around for more of it for you i mean
obviously i wasn't
meant to be and i what you were do you
not remember no i was going parasailing
yeah right after my start remember that
but i mean like at the point when i
started working
like we really we lost touch a bit
because i was so
busy doing that i feel like i missed out
on being
super supportive through all of that for
you
because i was going through my own
changes and my own stuff the popularity
of the show and work and all that we
hung out a few times but
you were so there for me it's so wild
that you don't remember that because you
were
completely there for me i mean that's
great to hear but i don't
feel like i was there enough i know now
about
stuff that you went through and things
and i really wish that you never felt
alone for any of that because that
that sucks i think we all must have felt
lonely in some ways or at least some of
us more than others
i know that in retrospect and watching
these videos
throughout the doc i deal with some
really
painful moments and also
ghosts of the past of people whom i love
so much who
are no longer here although i feel like
their angel wings are
surrounding me right yeah they're still
here i think of
jonathan brandes who i love so much
i love you joy i love her
i've always loved her i did the pilot
for save by the bell
with jonathan and uh jaleel white
i had no idea we were kids when we were
doing that and
we'd known each other for so long it's
amazing that people
are able to mask that much pain
that situation hit me hard because i've
known jonathan for so long
and that was the first smack in the face
of like
oh this isn't we're we're not
superheroes
we can only take so much like we are
living breathing people we're delicate
you know
things can go wrong so fast
so easily so that was a reminder of that
for me
so is jonathan i don't know if you got
my message last night
it's about 10 o'clock we used to leave
these voicemails for each other right
and do you remember how you'd fill up
each other's machine right
so jonathan would leave these like 20 30
minute messages and just be like i'm
gonna keep talking
until your machine is filled
right and it was so incredible because
you know i'd press pound right or nine
or whatever you would do to fast forward
it and
go to the next one after like 15 minutes
of listening to it
and as i was listening to the tapes back
in the last two minutes or one minute
he would start sharing his feelings like
his
deep feelings of how he really felt and
what a gift to be able to
to hear him from the other side you know
and and it just goes to this thing
around
how often things are happening around us
and we just
don't see it that's when you start
getting in your head you start
worrying about what you're wearing or
how you're walking or what you're doing
or
how you're perceived it was the first
time that i was like
really aware of learning
to be who i want to be
do you feel in the world in which your
kids are interested in getting into the
business do you feel like protecting
them
from it or would you be open to it i'm
not sure how to be honest
it's changed so much from when
we were kids and in the business i kind
of feel like
the best thing i can do as a parent is
just make sure that
my kids morally have a good sense of
right and wrong and what makes them feel
good and not and what
what affects other people negatively or
positively and then
put them out there and hope that they
can navigate it i'm just trying to give
them
as much of what i've learned and who i
am
as possible and then hope that that's
enough i love you brian
i love your i love your family i love
what an amazing dad you are i feel like
we're we've always been on the same path
we've we've taken different things but
we
you and i are headed somewhere together
always have been always i think always
will be yeah
i love you bro i love you too i can't
believe you have this
you know we would just talk for two
three hours
at night if if we hadn't seen each other
that day and and even
you know fall asleep on on the phone
and we were just so close so i have to
say
that you were really someone that
inspired me to go on this journey
right do you remember encouraging me to
open up this box of tapes
i do yeah i i remember very clearly
having a lot of conversations with you
and it
it just became more and more apparent in
a way that
you know this was your story and um and
that
you could see these other stories
through through your eyes
a lot of the documentary is about the
experiences that we all had
tell me what is one of your favorite
memories
of us probably the now infamous
uh prom that i took you to for those of
you that don't know
i took solei moon fry to her prom and
ended up throwing her in the ocean
you actually carried me
we walked in together as sort of the
topping on the cake
at the end of the night and i just
remember
coming to your house a lot when we were
young and always feeling like the love
that your mom created there and then
that you guys had and it was always such
a
like a fun um safe place you know one of
my favorite stories of us
of course is our motorcycle story i sort
of stole a
motorcycle and ended up
driving it from hollywood out out to
your house and
uh pretty sure the cops pulled us over
and
maybe we ended up like it's a cop
i think you were like 12. 12. i think
i was probably 13 14 maybe
yeah i guess i really wanted to see you
i mean you are
you and your family are some of the
closest people in my life there was such
a small group of us
growing up and those friendships and how
intertwined they were
and how they continue on today yeah i
mean it's
it still is but it was a smaller town
back then you know if you were in the
industry and
you know we all knew each other sort of
ran in the same
circles and and then as a smaller group
of us
forged lifelong relationships
so i unlocked my vault i have a little
vault
that has been unlocked to share with you
okay
okay i'm getting nervous see if i can
figure out okay i knew eventually i
wanted to do something in the film
industry uh
i didn't think i'd pursue it at such a
young age so uh
yeah something um writing directing
acting but
i didn't think you know i'd be here oh
my god
you have to send that to me look at look
at how grown up you are we're so
wise as teenagers yeah i mean
wow that i didn't even know that existed
i'm a big kid we're both big kids at
heart right
definitely and i mean that's why i had
kids
early i don't know there's a purity and
and uh
you know they're still kind of connected
in a different way
than than us than us grown-ups you know
now
who was balt getty in the 90s
i know who he was to me who do you
remember him big i was a young
cocky kind of a smart ass
but was raised well by a lot of
great women i was a little bit of a
troublemaker
sort of connected with
kind of a rough crowd when i was when i
was young
even though my childhood was crazy and
there was a lot of
you know a lot of pain and and a lot of
uncertainty and stuff like that i feel
like i have my mother gave us a lot of
love
and so um i have really
good memories of of those days you know
at times
we were very adult and then at times we
were really kids right
um how hard has that been
in reconciling with growing up i mean i
can remember just being
kind of thrown to the wolves at you know
a young age and then
having to having to navigate that yeah i
think it depends on like what your
experience was right
i can jump higher than most boys in my
class i can hit harder
and i can spit further what do i need a
boy for because each production is very
different at punky we were always on
pogo sticks and
scooters and other friends you know had
a very adult-like experience around them
it's interesting
yeah i mean you know my my first thing
as you know was
you know lord of the flies
if you guys had let the goddamn fire go
out they would have seen it
face it jack you [ __ ] up we could have
been rescued 13
being dropped on an island you know with
20 30 other guys
and there was almost no supervision at
all
and you know we almost started creating
the environment
and i think it was by design but it
almost started
mirroring the film sort of what was
happening yeah
offset because it was just a group you
know 30 guys
uh you know on an island yeah it was
wild what what they
allowed us to get away with i remember
when you came home
because i saw you in new york and i
think i snuck out with you
and we ran around new york and it was as
if this experience
had really unleashed the wild in you
i remember meeting up with you
afterwards i was doing press
and uh in new york um you know
for me it was like i never
and and it says it right there and in in
the little interview you know i
i didn't set out to become an actor per
se you know it
if you know my story it just sort of
happened right place the right time and
you know a bunch of things aligned and
the next thing i knew i was hanging out
with funky brewster in new york
it's amazing there was a few
years stretch in there where it seemed
like
i was losing a friend every week so many
of the people that we loved so deeply
passed away
and didn't make it here too
what was that like watching back
the footage it's sad and and you know
you wonder if
things have been a little bit different
you know if they would have survived and
um
it's it's really touching you know we
have lost a lot of people
and you just realize nothing's
guaranteed
and while we're here we have to love our
family and our friends
and and try to be the best
you know best people we can so
true so many of us are parents now how
protective do you feel like you have to
be of your kids
in this industry in the world in which
they want to
act or perform luckily or depending on
how you want to
see it none of my kids want to be
in the business per se but
look i mean to be a parent is to
you know is to be there to
protect them to guide them but also
allow them
you know to make mistakes you know you
have to strike that balance where where
you want to take care of them um but i
also know from experience that
you know it's good to trip and fall we
have been friends for so many years
what is something that you have always
wanted me to ask you
we've always had great conversations you
know and
we're both can be very chatty you know
we used to fall asleep on the phone at
night after we speak for two or
three hours so i think we probably asked
each other uh
every question
you